she pulled off a bingo at five in a row
almost got
hit in the last round
carissa we know it's hard all of us have
been veterans of this chess world it's
hard to play a last round when there's
nothing to play for did you get caught
with this bug
i mean
yeah probably i was playing
it's really not playing my vest so to
speak enough
during the game i was kind of like
what are you doing fine why is your
position so trashed why are you playing
so trash
uh but but you definitely let me back in
the game um
many times
so
yeah i'm glad to now i've lost this one
yesterday you won the championship you
went home
what was the response from family and
friends
oh well everyone was like congratulating
me and
and i was just trying to write my
college application essays because
they're due soon and i've been
neglecting them for this tournament
so
yeah the grind never stops
the grind never stops indeed your
parents did you get a chance to talk to
them oh yeah
my dad's here with me
and and my mom's back home so so i gave
her a call
what did she have to say
oh she was like freaking actually
thinking
and then she like texted like this big
family group chat with all of our like
extended relatives and they're all like
oh my god
it's very sweet that's fantastic those
friends are yours who said uh that you
need to keep your brain in the game
because you're only a half a point down
after that bad loss the bad loss earlier
what about them did they have anything
to say oh yes of course they were like
well after that bad loss i was like guys
do you think i can still win this
tournament
and they're like yeah of course and then
and then yesterday they were all like
hey you remember when you were asking if
you're going to win this tournament like
a week ago
told you you'd be fine
cool absolutely well we will see you
collect the championship trophy at the
ceremony tomorrow and you can relax and
go write your college applications which
what's your top college on your mind is
it uh christian carrillo's college
mizzou yes of course it has to be
yes definitely it's on my list
to see me next fall christian
i hope to see you at the zoo that's for
sure he's smiling i'm sure alejandro is
saying the fix is on wait a minute what
about slu i'm writing the scholarship
letter right now
i'm going to hand it to her tomorrow i'm
not sure i'm not sure that's legal what
you're doing christian you got to be
careful i'm going to get myself in
trouble
all right well congratulations carissa
you're the champ and glad to see you
didn't lose the last game and you can go
relax yes thank you
welcome bravo bravo
uh carissa
and once again we just got to just jump
back into the
games of alexander